To identify genetic factors that may be involved
in a particular trait, we conduct something called a
Genetic Association Study. Now these studies take people with
a trait, for example a skin condition and really
they take a whole population of people with
this trait and they compare their genetics to an
individual or really a group of individuals. Without this
particular trait. In this case without the skin condition.
Now what we're going to do is look at a
genetic factor, or more. And we're going to see which
variants each population has. Now if a certain genetic
variant is observed more frequently than you would expect
by chance, in the actual cases, than the controls.
Then it's good evidence that it might be involved
in the trait. Suppose that we have 1,000 people
that have a particular kind of skin rash and
we compare them to 1,000 people that don't have
this particular kind of skin rash. Now let's say we
analyze these two populations. For one particular genetic factor.
And let's saw we determine that 50% of the population
with the skin rash has a cytosine for this
genetic factor at a given position and that in the
control population only 20% have a cytosine. Now at that
same position, the only other option that we can have.
Is an adenine. And our affected population, the
othe50%, the remaining 50%, have an adenine. And in
our control population, the remaining, in this case 80%,
have an adenine. Now we have a lot of
people in our population, a thousand. If this letter
was insignificant to this particular trait. We would expect
that with so many people that these numbers would
be more similar. 50, 50, 50, 50, or 20,
80, 20, 80 in both situations. In other words, these
differences are greater than what we would expect to see by
chance. So, based on this scenario here, I want you to
tell me which of the following is the most reasonable conclusion.